Let's solve a few word problems.
They say 5% will be added this year.
If your salary is $ 45,000, how much
you had before the increase?
Let's say my previous salary was x.
x equals previous salary.
And I'll add a 5% increase to this salary.
So x + 5% zx, plus 5% · x ... that's my addition
here ... will be my new salary.
Well, my new salary, they tell us how much it will be.
It's $ 45,000.
And let's see if we can do it a bit mathematically
pohrát.
5% is the same as 0.05, 5%
Per cent literally means "out of a hundred."
So it's the same as 5/100.
This is 5%, out of 100, the same as 0.05
So we can say it's the same as 1x plus ...
I'll write it x beautifully ... 1x plus 0.05x is
equal to 45000.
1 of anything + 0.05 of the same thing.
We can put coefficients together.
So we add these two.
So we get 1.05x equals 45000.
And now we'll solve for x, divide both sides by 1.05
Here it goes.
And now we got x equals 45000 / 1.05
And let's figure out how much it is.
So 45 ... 1, 2, 3 ... 45000 dollars divided by 1.05 with
equals $ 42,857.
I'll say $ 42,857 again.
This is your annual income for last year.
Let's make sure it makes sense.
Let's see if it works.
So we'll check it out, we'll start with this
Consider 5%
So times 0.05 equals ... that's the increase I got
plus old pay, plus 42857.
And of course, we've rounded it up a bit,
so it won't be exactly accurate.
It equals almost $ 45,000.
We have 14 cents less.
So $ 45,000.
That confirms the answer
Let's do another one.
It costs $ 250 ... I'll write it down here ... it costs $ 250
put the carpet in room 14 on 18.
How much will it cost to put a carpet in room 9 on 10?
And the units here are tracks (1 foot is about 30.5 cm)
Well, if you've never laid a rug, normally
you lay the carpet according to the size of the room or
by square feet of room. (For us by square meters).
So what can we do?